that's all so far we we certainly
concern undirected graph assuming also
that it's regular which simplifies some
notation on door doesn't effect almost
any of the results we'll talk about so
then we define these normalized
laplacian matrix which is symmetric and
we look at the atom values of of this
matrix with multiplicity we call them
lambda 1 up to lambda and increasing
order so in the first two lectures we
talked about what are the extrema and
nearly extremal values for lambda over
lambda and kind of properties of the
graph can be derived in from knowledge
of lambda 2 or lambda so today I want to
say more about what happens when you
have some knowledge about additional
eigenvalues of the laplacian matrix so
first let's look at the extremal case
for inspiration so we know that if
lambda K is 0 G has scaled more quality
components so J admits a partition
s12 SK of the vertices such that each si
has no edge going on
and if say lambda k is positive then
what we can say is that that we can find
if I know more the chaotic component so
we can find sets no more like a minus
120 components so let's call this k plus
1 so you can find again a partition s 1
plus K the vertices such that each si
induces a connected subgraph vertex a
new server
so now that the way she talked about the
the general case would be that neuron
zero should transform to small positive
should transform to large an isolated
set of vertices should become a set of
loss conductance and the set of vertices
inducing a connected subgraph should be
a set of voltages inducing an expanding
subgraph so now we know how to argue
more at each of these analogies so so as
an analogy of the first result it's
known that paragraph g there may be in
the case it's it's true for a partition
but possible to just think about genetic
substance so the G has K subsets s 1 to
s K / this is disjoint such that each of
them has more conductance
if lambda k is one
and this is an if and only so if it has
K subsets of vertices that are disjoint
and all of small conductance then lambda
K has to be small
so just as we can say lambda is 3 if and
only if there are K disjoint subsets
each with no edge Akane note we can say
the lambda K is small if and only if
there are K subsets each with a few
ideas coming up if you is not really
counting the edges but it's looking when
you can set si what is the total degree
of the British in Si so that's up to
factor of 2 how many edges touch si
so having small conductance the
conductance epsilon means that of this
number of incident edges only an epsilon
fraction leaves the set a1 minus EPSA
fraction stays in salt so in a graph
lambda Kevlar clashing can be small if
and only if there are K subsets such
that for each of them almost all the
incident edges stay inside and you have
the same quadratic laws that you see in
the sugar inequality for lambda 2 but
this can be made this can be made to
look a bit more like the sugar sugar
inequality for k equal to so we could
define this notion of order k expansion
or maybe other cake inductances so it's
at listening would be the same when we
go to the non regular case so here in
the in the regular case this would be
defined the following way for disjoint
sets s1 to escape the order k
conductance is just the largest
conductance
and then they were decay conductance of
a graph is the is the one of the
smallest collection of disjoint sets you
can also define for partitions it will
be the same after factor of K
that's the did you say in Toronto fire
in K disjoint sets what's the best I can
do in terms of making sure that each of
them has fewer edges coming out so then
that result can be stated in the
following way the other K conductance of
G is at least lambda K over 2 and at
most some point easy just shake is 4 K
squared square root of lambda K so for k
equal to this is just the conductance
the edge expansion if the graph is
regular and so this is the triggered
inequality with the word snotty
Wisconsin so here maybe for k equal to
this might be 30 or 40 instead of being
the square root of 2 and the co general
kid gives this kind of trade off so the
only way for a graph to a small lambda k
of the laplacian is that there are
several disjoint sets each known as
funny so for example if your graph looks
like this that this is a highly
expanding graph this is a highly
expanding graph and then there are this
small number of edges going across and
this is a graph for which lambda 3
cannot be small because if it were you
will be able to find three disjoint sets
each non expanding but then one of those
three sets would have to not really cut
one of the expanders and then that side
come not a small expansion
so this is sort of the robust analog of
this fact so we don't quite have a
perfect analog of of this but we know
several facts about graphs were one of
the first few laplacian eigenvalues is
large but larger than some constant so
one thing that we know is that many
algorithm problems that seem very hard
to solve in the worst case for general
graphs become considerably easier in
graphs were lambda K is 1 to some K so
they become so low point time that is
exponential in K instead of being
exponential in the number of vertices
yeah so so this this inequality comes
from seeing lambda K as a relaxation and
this type is constructed
so what substitutes this when you had
this thing that we think of this
ah yes sir we can its you can actually
just make sure that I stayed all things
on to stay then talk about viruses are
then I would see how many proofs so they
just be instead of marking like this is
relying you'd not vertices to a
k-dimensional space
so for example if each lambda k is a
sufficiently large constant times the
expansion of the drug then walking at a
conservative approximation if are given
a 1 plus epsilon approximation if you
want one perception approximation this
will have to be something like 1 over
epsilon square times the expansion of
the expansion in time exponentially
but in there we don't know how to find
the cause of our approximation of the
expansion in sub-exponential time in
fact if you could find a cost about
approximation of expansion in per unit
time in general graphs that would refute
the unique games conjecture in this form
this is the coolest one is you know I
think it is for one cook a lot of Arabic
so there is also a sort of smoking proof
in this Quran weekly Idol
our graph G is in which lambda is large
so I can show that this sort of a
constant size model that depends on K
and how large is lambda K that is a very
good approximation of the graphing
cognitive and so that leads to to the
party one can approximate many graph
problems like Max car in time only
exponential in K in absolutely lambda 2
is bigger than 0 he grabs the regular
say language is bigger than 0 mesa grabs
an expander is Omega 1 yeah yeah for a
family letter - it stays above 0 for
family in the regular graphs and you
must have it it must be expanded so is
very analogous result here maybe if you
like the cake stays above 0 for
Democrats there's some structure
no so someone will imagine that the
Ratana would be to say if your family
grants were lambda k stays like at least
epsilon we should be possible to find a
maybe to cover most of the vertices or
even more vertices with a body number of
cells each of them inducing the neck
spanning sub graph so in order to argue
some consequences of this but in this
form result is open is there even one
can you get one extender lie can you say
that this must be because of an X Factor
especially the several things about the
guff isn't this fun
yeah yeah I think you should be able to
cover most of the work
which with small tendon fibers but not a
very public air quality this has been
clean but we but what we cannot do is
they have a lot of this but if lambda K
is zero and lambda k plus 1 is positive
so that can have just exactly K quality
components
have stronger think if Linda is really
if later K is 0 in that blame that P
plus 1 is bigger than some constant then
you can say it's not only connected as
an expansion there this room so so one
so we can say that then one extreme one
not less extreme aversion to say if
lambda K is zero and lambda k plus 1 is
epsilon then then in this case each
multi component has to be an expander
bit otherwise a non expanding cut among
those components would give you another
yes thank you so so this is the the one
it is an hour Lisa teapot which we have
a good understanding so if so if the
order k plus one expansion is
sufficiently larger than the order k
expansion in fact i mean just a tiny bit
more then we can find any can find
suggests algorithmic then there exist
a partition of the Sun in two cases
sorry in two cases such that each each
of the sets has small outside conductors
which is bounded by Phi K maybe there is
a dependence in K here and but also each
cell induces an expanding sub graph
again there is some dependence on
so if you think about these higher-order
expansions instead of thinking about the
eigenvalues even a small gap is giving
you what you would expect a partition of
the vertices into subsets such that each
set as fewer edges going out but also
when you focus on that side you see an
expander so that a partition like this
can only be achieved in one way because
by any other way of cutting a graph
would cut those expanders and you would
get sites of higher conductance
this is a when this relates to
quantities that are np-hard to compute
so the proof itself is not constructive
but if if lambda k plus 1 is
sufficiently bigger than the square root
of lambda k again with some dependence
on k then we can do then we can do the
same
so here we call it all vertices with
this joint sets and each of them has
small outside conductance that depends
on lambda king
with some dependence of K but large
inside expansion that depends on lambda
k plus one
so this is a kind of partition that I
think it was face canal and Ben [ __ ]
all the strong cluster so something were
your partition of the graph so that
every class there is George is going
down but also it's minimal in a sense
that when you look inside the class
there is no good way of cutting it so if
this is a graph that represents a
similarity relation and there is this
kind of eigenvalue lab this is saying
the sets with this probability should be
possible to find so all that these
dependencies are polynomial in k but it
should be possible although we don't
know to get dependence logarithmic in k
if one is willing to get some outliers
vertices or some other kind of slackness
in the condition no unless we sort of
interpolated and find some I and I plus
one where there's a gap but then we lose
too much in in doing that we don't know
I mean we don't have a good sense of
what kind of what would be good counter
example graphs to think about to see
what's impossible now we just try to
yeah we don't have a good sense of
what's not possible in this
is that that's that you complete I mean
you can prove this root theorem the
first the one above the line but the
it's empty complete actually solve this
don't find this Phi K or to find those
partitions yeah it was a know like I
mean conceivably this could be
approximated I don't know but they
[ __ ] them such that at least as hard
as expansion because you can always are
the isolated components so you know I've
some birthday I some graph I can make
five four be equal to the expansion of
the graph that I started from by adding
two isolated highly expanding components
so those numbers are hard
those partition again getting a constant
approximation for Phi K is as hard as
finding close approximation for
expansion and get a motion if I know
this has been written down but I think
you can get some maybe root loci root
log and approximation for Phi K like the
natural extension of air being as it
being written up I heard something like
this some time ago are you
so it's yeah so you can get some
approximation but it's always at least
as hard as expansion so that's about the
neck for how good things can be yeah
square root lambda K yeah I mean again
you even just for one set
you wouldn't okay so yeah you wouldn't
expect to do better than this without
being able to do better than root lambda
2 versus expansion in the in the basic
case so you have sudden analysis of
spatial partitioning where you get
lambda 2 over square root lambda K yes
something like that that works here that
you can get lambda K over square root
lambda k plus 1 right so we can do that
okay I mean and let me get to this all
right so so here's what we get out of
the other words petrol gap again if just
lambda K is large yeah there is this
idea a small one should cover the graph
should be able to cover the graph by
expanders but I don't know a
satisfactory result that says that
what what who is telling you that you
are going to find some edge inside they
expanded partition the graph into things
where they do some graphs are expanders
this is known or follows from this we
know to do now we gotta get and then I
remember we have a sequence of grass and
you know the lambda K is bounded from
below then somehow you you get a gap
somewhere because okay so then it would
be you there will be loss that is like K
to the K or some tower
it was written okay well now it's
everybody will edit it before any
personal so this is something kind of
small that you can argue about this
craft the diameter of a job is it most
what is it k times one over lambda k I
mean if G is connected otherwise this
will apply to each connected component
times log n I mean this is a two line
proof but the the reason why it's
vaguely related is that suppose that you
really have a KX panders and that the
graph is connected in in some way
I mean K expanders a sum of each of
again value gap lambda K
well then you would expect that so then
each of those graphs if it's really an
expander within an expansion depends on
lambda K each of these little graphs are
sort of induced subgraphs would have
diameter a 1 over lambda K times log n
because the diameter is always at most
the special gap times log n if at the
mixing time is this much but then you
never need to hop through more than K or
those exponents to go from anywhere to
anywhere so you would expect this upper
bound
so now we're back to fact that when
lambda K is large one thing we know how
to argue is that solution the many
columns become easier than in the worst
case is that if this intuition about the
graph being made of K expanders plus
extra edges is true when you solve many
convex relaxations of graph partitioning
problems say some kind of SDP say the
gameís Williams relaxation for max cut
okay that's the wrong example say the
air via relaxation of sparse is cut then
in your solution it will be not really
advantageous to spread out your vector
solution inside those sets because then
that would cost you a lot in the
solution so you'd expect the optimum of
air V or other convex lock sessions for
sparse s cartel problems to concentrate
the output in such a way that the
vectors that vertices get mapped to
concentrate in just in case mode regions
so Lenny if you go K levels up in the
lesser hierarchy after conditioning you
get the echo support approximation and
in any case you can see that something
like log K your root loci approximation
that's much better than the worst case
and in fact this kind of concentration
of the solutions can be proved even if
we don't know exactly the expansion
thing going on
so one more that I want to mention and
maybe I'll get back to this to answer
now this question is that this
concentration of the solutions can be
seen even in the spectral setting
remember they trigger inequality for
expansion says that the expansion of a
graph is at most the square root of 2
lambda 2 and it is not just the
expansion of the graph that is like this
it's that the the best cut as b---minus
as they can be found
just by taking a threshold to the
eigenvector of lambda to
and we know that in some cases this is
this is best possible because the even
the best cut not even the best card that
we find out of this argument is really
the square root of lambda 2 first up we
name in an nth cycle the expansion is 1
over 2 over n because the best cut is
this balanced cut and here we have so
there are two edges coming out and then
either side as n over 2 vertices and the
versa
and the volume is 2 times n over 2
but lambda2 of the cycle is of the order
of one over N square and one way to see
that the spot this is not the this is
not the actual eigenvector but if you if
you have your cycle and you so you can
always think of an eigenvector is
mapping the vertices on the line and
then the corresponding lambda to the
corresponding Rayleigh quotient will be
what's the average distance square
between endpoints of edges divided by
the average distance square of random
pairs of vertices so if you like that is
taking a while
so if you if you have your cycle like
this so say this is like - another two
and this is another - when you look at a
random pair of vertices it's a distance
constant times n square cause that I'm
sent on the line when you square it it's
concept times n square but every edge is
a distance one so when you so if this is
your X this emission over the edges of X
2 minus X 3 squared divided by the
summation over V of X v square so the
numerator will be order of N and
denominator will be order of n cube
Omega so for some graphs this inequality
is tight so that's sort of the integrity
gap a type instance for this relaxation
but this is the second solution that is
possible for the cycle and many other
graphs in which the embedding produced
by the eigenvector is very spread out
you don't see any kind of concentration
of vertices in a few places
so instead so that's an extra in general
hi welcome to the Tyler
inequality so here is a fairly
reasonable constant
and this applies not just to the best
cut in a graph but the best threshold
cut using the eigenvector of lambda to
and this is true for every k so when you
take k equal to this is just saying well
it's at most root lambda two but if you
have a graph where lambda is very small
but say lambda five is very large
maybe lambda 2 is 1 over N but lambda 5
is 1/10 this is telling you that the
kind of expansion are going to get will
not be 1 over root n will be 1 over N
the so the only way of putting it that
the approximation that you get out of
the this threshold cut algorithm will be
the minimum over K of K of a root loci
this might not be any better because in
some cases cannot then the standard
analysis but in graph slap some kind of
eigenvalue gap it gives better analysis
and the way this follows is similar to
the way you get better approximation
using semi definite programs when lambda
K is large which is that when lambda K
is large it will always be optimal for
the eigenvector to concentrate points
not to spread them around will give some
intuition for for this
so the idea is the following first we're
given this to analyze how this threshold
cut algorithm works so this is the
embedding in which we map every vertex V
so we're given this vector X ok so now I
want to give another complete proof but
some of the other you argue this and
then if there is time I'll give somebody
of how you argue that so essentially so
in order to argue this I need to show
that when lambda K is large there is
some gain that I can make over the
standard analysis and this gain will
come from the fact that if lambda K is
much larger than lambda 2 it will be
necessary for the eigenvector to not
spread out the points too much but to
concentrate them and then will it argue
that one day I can factor concentrates
points the in not too few enough too
many different places then the analysis
of the threshold cut algorithm can be
improved
so how does the analysis of the
threshold cut algorithm work in general
first you are given this eigenvector in
fact need not be an eigenvector just
some vector for which really quotient is
small then you so you think of this as
embedding the vertices on the line so
that every vertex V gets mapped to the
point X sub B and then every edge will
gain a certain length and the property
that we have about X is that the average
length squared of edges in this
embedding is small compared to the
average distance squared of random pairs
of points so now the first thing we do
is that we shift it so that the median
of this embedding stays at zero and then
we look at which of the two sides by
itself gives better really quotient and
we keep that so let's say the positive
side needs a better really question so
this means that with no loss in the
Rayleigh quotient we just push half of
the vertices to 0 so not to scale these
are the vertices at 0 and there are all
the edges between them so this will
always be on one side of the cut and we
just need to decide how to get the what
subset of these other vertices to pick
in our cut and hopefully improve over
the standard analysis so we have we have
our vertices here and there now the
first thing we'll do is to find a
optimal k-means clustering of of the
line so we want to basically partition
the line into K blocks and what we want
to minimize is for every block what is
the distance
squared from the sum over the vertices
inside the block of the width distance
squared to the closest barrier so for a
moment I forget that there are any edges
in this graph
I'm just looking at points on the line
and then I want to see if there is a way
to and then I want to look at some way
of partitioning the line into K blocks
that minimizes the max over the blocks
of the distance square of each point to
the closest barrier so if if the parents
were kind of clustered around in in K
positions then I would pick the I want
to pick the barriers like this and if
the points are very are very spread out
but doesn't really matter if you not
make much difference what they do maybe
they would be evenly spaced so in this
case
yeah because then later I will use those
intervals that's why I shouldn't call
them very yeah these art centers so I
want to find the K centers so that I
minimize the max over the Centers of the
distance squares of the way to do it so
let's look at the two cases I want to
minimize over the choice of centers the
maximum with the Centers of the some of
the so imagine that I just after I
picked the centers I just want to move
every point to its closest center and
then I want to find some way in which
each center needs like not a lot of
movement square for the vertices
together and so the optimum will balance
the two things so that for every Center
it will be the same so let's say these
two extreme cases the world cluster case
and the poorly cluster place
so they're in the in a world class case
our eigenvector is very well
approximated by a vector in which the
entries take only K distinct values
because instead of my vector X I could
construct a new vector for which every
vertex gets mapped to its center instead
of where it is and that doesn't change
things a lot
so maybe that's not the clearest way of
expressing it by the day in this case X
is close to some back to such that there
are only capable values for its entrance
in the in the booty clustered case I got
that in each interval between centers so
they did this would be very rough way of
saying it but each interval between
centers so an interval like this and the
interval like this and so on has a lot
of points in the middle
because either if if the vertices were
away from the middle they would be close
to the centers and we would be in the
world cluster case so let's say this is
case 1 and this is 2 so then what we so
what we need to argue is that in case 1
the the threshold cut algorithm works
better than in the worst case and that
in case 2 lambda K is small
so then the two things balance to the
threshold cut only always working well
when lambda K is large and so the
precise quantitative statement is like
this so why would you expect those two
things to happen well imagine that the
points were perfectly clustered so that
already
you just have one solution where the the
vertices get mapped to only K distinct
values so then you can do an analysis of
the threshold cut algorithm this shows
that you get a cut the costs at most k
times lambda 2 so there is no quadratic
loss in lambda 2 there is only a loss in
K I mean the idea that doesn't work like
this would be to say well I'm going to
pick one of the K centers at random and
the summer one is right and I've
probably 1 over K of missing it but that
is similar where the probabilities
depend on the distance squared between
the clusters work and then you need a
robust version of this the sort of mix
is the cauchy-schwarz thing going on in
the standard analysis with this idea of
preferring to be a clusters and then
what you get is that there is an upper
bound that is like K times lambda 2
times how much is the correction that
you need to go from your vector to a
vector with only K distinct time trees
and then this correction so and stop
giving you the one with root lambda K so
about case 2
why would you expect in this case lambda
K to be small so to prove the lambda K
is small you need to come up with a k
dimensional set of vectors each with
small really quotient so so but it's
actually enough to come up with K
disjoint Lee supported vectors each with
small relic quotient so K vectors for
each of them the Rayleigh quotient is
small but those vectors are nonzero in
these joint coordinates and so then
everything in their span will also have
small Rayleigh quotient up to a factor
of 2 so we want to find in the second
case K disjoint Lee supported vectors
each with a small relic quotient which
means K the jointly supported embeddings
of vertices on the line such that in
each of them which ot support that means
K ways of mapping vertices to the line
such that when you look at what vertices
are mapped not to 0 those are disjoint
sets in each of the K cases and also we
want this mapping to be such that when
you look at the distance squared of the
typical edge that's small compared to
the distance square of the typical pair
of vertices so these are our constraints
and the idea will be that each of those
intervals we will explore each of these
intervals to get one of those vectors
and what we will do for each interval is
to construct a vector or small relic
question entirely supported on the
vertices in this interval so then
automatically we will get vectors of
this joint support
so the sum of the first day I would come
to mind if you want to do this would be
to say well I want to get an embedding
only of these vertices being nonzero
everybody else needs to be 0 so you just
sort of take this and map all the other
vertices to T so this has the advantage
when you look at what's going on with
the distance squared or edges that the
distance square of all the other edges
becomes 0 that's good the distance
square of all the edges inside here
stays what it is that's good but then if
you have if you have an edge like this
so maybe and blow this up so this is the
interval with the vertices and you want
to construct some new embedding so this
goes on a wall in both directions you
want to go start some new embedding of
the vertices on the line where those are
the only vertices not mapped to 0 and so
that as I said the first thing comes to
mind is to take all the other vertices
and put them to see but the problem is
with edges like this because if you just
take all those vertices and put them to
0 0 visibly far away that way now this
edge becomes stretched a lot because
this was like arbitrarily small and now
that were that goes to 0 it's so one way
to avoid this is to is to do things with
a smoother cut off so just saying I want
to keep these vertices where they are
and map everybody else to 0 it's a bit
like saying I I have this I have this
sharp of this indicator 0 one function
and then for every vertex I'm going to
multiply what is the value of the vertex
in imbedding by this cut off function
and at this point so then every vertex
here gets multiplied by zero and goes to
0 everywhere text here gets multiplied
by one in stage one now the product with
this sharp cut off is that when you look
at the difference between those two
points after this multiplication you can
get amplified a lot because it's a so
this continuous function so in a little
interval it can change a lot so when you
multiply two not two different numbers
you can get two very different numbers
so it's that you just want to do
something like this so that now they
depending is a bit harder to picture but
believe what you do is to take every
vertex and multiply it by this this mod
cut off function I mean there there are
many more kind of functions that would
work
so all those methods go to zero vertices
close to this Center also almost go to
zero vertices here stay where they are
so the effect is that the vertices in
this interval get spread out from here
up to two now what happens to the length
square of this edge well if this edge
was small the difference of the cut off
function at the end points is not very
big so even after multiplying by the cut
off function you still have a shortage
now the problem with this approach and
why you cannot do it in then you could
say okay I'll do it
for every graph I'll pick K intervals
and then do a cut off like this but the
problem would be if I had all the
vertices very close to these endpoints
now all the work will be mapped very
close to zero when I compute marilla
quotient this would be a problem for the
denominator because in a Rayleigh
quotient I divide by the sum square of
the of the vertices so if I send them to
zero I'm making my denominator equal to
zero and that's not good for direction
that's precisely the case it is not
happening here I mean all the vertices
close to the centers is precisely not
the case in which we are that most
parties are away from the center yeah
use the structure of to do something
about the behavior something hires off
you're a sort of surprising is there an
intuition for what kind of information
about stuff higher the spectrum we are
able to extract from is very low yeah so
if somehow you can always look at
vectors as witnesses that tell you
something about the eigenvalues even
vectors are not like in vectors like if
I give you some vector whose entry sum
to zero and who's really quotient is
small then you can say well lambda 2 has
to be small
maybe so that doesn't need to be an
eigenvector for this information to be
there now what I'm saying here is that
if I gave you a vector whose entry sum
to zero who's really quotient is small
and whose entry is kind of spread out
among the set of possible values then
I'm telling it's not just the witness
that lambda two is zero it's a witness
that even the lambda is small it's also
a witness that lambda K is small because
I can take this vector and cut it up and
smoothen out and do these operations and
then I will get a key witnesses that
together testify that lambda K is mod
I just know they took the eigenfunction
on like the Cape I can function on the
line and just put it on drew it on top
of your picture and you would
automatically get to these data you
would automatically get the functions
you want
yeah that's not advice so if you so if
you look at this cycle and so that's a
graph in which even lambda K is small
and so let's testify by K so then it has
this K eigen vectors and from the cycle
on to your graph and say there you have
a k-dimensional space that function on
this cycle and now because we have this
nice embedding which says that your
graph on average looks like the cycle
path then you can just pull them back
that's awesome of course I said make it
up phenomena it looks like a inve I mean
no worse than because you have a nice
and baby I mean this looks like an
eigenvector of the cycle but my graph
could I mean agreed and that's in pretty
much a similar way when I when I look at
the second eigenvalue you have this map
from you you can you can take the
eigenfunction a cycle and you can define
a function on your graph and put it back
to you that it won't in general it just
won't say anything but it seems that
here is this kind of what you're doing
because you have a nice curve map from
your rest
never even expected live there anything
but press that are like Cartesian
products then this is not gonna tell you
anything about the whole other part of
the space like grid or something like
that right
the square grid or a tree cross a line
or some other kind of thing cuz that
you're only going to understand about
one of the half stuff you know it small
part of the graph well now you're only
gonna see most all vertices are gonna be
we are gonna be huge copies of vertices
with the same value right but so maybe
the contrapositive of this argument is
more limiting so it's not that we are
looking at the Automator lambda 2 and we
are trying to understand something about
the higher spectrum of the graph in
general it's more that we in a sort of
offend on this way we just saying unless
the highest spectrum of the graph looks
in a certain way we are going to see
that the eigenvector of lambda 2 is
going to look like that
and that helps the cut the threshold cut
algorithm
so whenever whenever the gamma 2 lambda
2 is not looking like this but it looks
like that we cannot say that we
understand the highest spectrum we just
say there is a sort of slow eigenvalue
growth there is no eigenvalue gap so
this is true for so when you just look
at the second but it looks almost the
same for a cycle for a grid so somehow
so you know that you cannot tell the
difference between a cycle or already
just looking at this or even if you have
the if you have a real grid or if you
have a real grid where where these edges
have very small weight which is one of
the bad cases for a threshold cut
somebody will all protein
much look the same so what we can say in
that case is just that there is a slow
eigenvalue growth so it's a it's only
said what we can always do better in
finding a cut because either things are
concentrated and cut as well or else we
have some understanding of the highest
paid to and then we use that to do
something we're just saying either the
Dragon vector looks like this and then
we can do a better analysis of the
threshold cut algorithm or there is slow
again value growth that's a very genetic
information so that that's what we got
so that's why the interpretation for us
is the contrapositive it says suppose
you are promised that there is an
eigenvalue gap well then the threshold
cattle going will work better than in
the worst case in s the direction that
makes more sense
okay so next time is up but more
question